alright good morning everyone good
morning fellow game developers and all
the students indie developers media
press everybody hi I'd like you to
please silence your cell phones or put
them to vibrate mode before we get
started because I've got some cool audio
and it would really suck to hear like a
ringtone in the middle of that alright
as you all may have guessed my name is
linnea and i'm a lead artist at dice
during battlefield 4 I worked as a world
builder on the multiplayer portion of
our game and today I want to share some
behind-the-scenes just a quick look into
the making of battlefield so today I'm
going to go over the approach that we
had to the entire game our art direction
through various disciplines such as
animation characters effects you guys
can read I'm also going to go through
some of our tech that we upgraded which
gave us better destruction LEvolution
and a really big feature this time was
are synced water and weather systems I'm
going to talk a bit about how we worked
with those and what it was like to
change tech partway through a project so
during battlefield 4 or approaching that
project we had several challenges as
some of you may have no battlefield is a
very old franchise as far as the
industry is concerned we have a lot of
titles that have been out this is the
14th battlefield not including cancelled
projects and expansion packs there's
also a feeling from the consumer base
and from ourselves that the FPS market
was a little bit flooded I don't know if
any of you guys felt that way how many
of you play first-person shooters how
many of you play battlefield actually
okay great this you guys will know
exactly what I'm talking about them we
also had a changing audience space so a
lot of people that had started playing
battlefield way back in the day with
Vietnam 1942 and even people that had
started playing with bad company we're
suddenly notice
that they're getting older more mature
so we decided that our game should also
become a little bit more mature but we
still also had a lot of new players
coming in new players that had never
played battlefield before so we wanted
to make sure that we catered to them as
well we're also facing a new console
generation when we released we were one
of the first games to release on gem for
so we released on five consoles six if
you count low end and ultra pc as
different consoles which we did but it
was a bit of a headache worth it though
I think so we had some goals that we set
up in the beginning when we realized we
had these challenges we wanted more
destruction who doesn't want more
destruction destruction school we wanted
to listen to our players we want to make
sure that they felt like they were heard
like what they were suggesting what they
wanted made it into the game or at least
that we were trying we wanted to improve
in quality and innovation of course
that's like obvious stuff who wouldn't
want to get better at quality and
innovation and we also wanted no crunch
yeah good luck but we wanted no crunch
so that was our goal we had to we had to
have a goal in order to make some
progress in that direction so instead of
having more destruction we decided to
have smarter destruction because we
couldn't really add more the animations
require a lot of dynamic parts and a lot
of our performance would suffer and of
course we wanted to try to hit 60 FPS on
next-gen and ultra pc so instead we
decided to focus our efforts where it
mattered in changing the game play with
destruction on the big stuff that
players felt more rather than the small
aesthetic things that just ate up
performance and didn't really add much
to the feeling of the game like I said
we wanted to listen to our players so
that meant that we wanted to listen to
both our core players and also our new
players this is how we ended up creating
the multiplayer play ground level and a
lot of other smaller things but that's a
good example where we were listening
to a lot of our core players you know
they know how to fly a jet they know how
to fly a helicopter but if you're a new
player coming into a multiplayer game
and you jump in a helicopter and you're
not very good at it people yell at you
to say new get off the servers you know
uninstalling very mean things that I'm
not going to repeat here so we wanted to
give players a space where they could
test drive a bunch of these vehicles a
lot of weapons test out different ranges
how they felt test destruction test our
water gameplay before they got into a
match so that they would know what they
were doing and feel less intimidated by
all this peer pressure when it came to
quality and innovation we realized that
it was a bit of a balance between the
two because if you want to create
quality in an area you really need to
spend a lot of time polishing your
techniques training yourselves in those
areas but if you want to innovate then
you're creating new stuff so you don't
really have as much time to get the high
level of quality that dice is well known
for so we decided to have a bit of a
balance between the two we still wanted
to push boundaries and so we had
different trade-offs between polishing
certain areas like Battlelog and then
had to compete with adding elements like
commander mode now we took a lot of
these ideas and a lot of them we haven't
given up on so we have continued support
throughout the game and with our DLC
packs that's going to continue adding
features and polishing on segments that
we weren't managing to hit during our
regular production and of course crunch
always happens when you have developers
who are passionate about what they make
and are invested in it becoming great
and when eventually during production we
agreed to a release date we really don't
want to upset the players and ourselves
by pushing that and pushing that and
continuously pushing that so we decided
we're going to ship at a certain date
and some of us really wanted to get our
features that extra mile better so we
spent a little bit of extra hours but
our studio is really great with
encouraging healthier options working
out time off they encourage vacation and
spending time with the family
I don't think there were many people at
our studio that had families that really
were spending many more extra hours so I
wanted to go over some key areas that we
focused on with our art direction
throughout the entirety of battlefield 4
because there are so many different
components we wanted to have some common
threads working their way through our
entire game this was for both
multiplayer and single player but also
for different areas such as characters
animations the effects audio so I'll go
through each of those a bit human was
the first area we wanted to improve in
we wanted everything to feel more human
more relatable so we had a new tech like
blend shapes scanning techniques new I
shaders to the characters our animated
characters should become aware of the
player and have an egocentric system so
that you felt like they reacted to you
being there not just standing there like
a pillar the effects should pull the
player into the world audio should sound
more human and be more human in their
movement and interactions and the music
we decided will also be a bit more
organic and human in its feeling Antone
less dubstep II than last time so here's
an example from battlefield 3 what we
were trying to get away from were these
moments of uncanny valley that really
pull you out of the immersion of the
game as you can see these are moments
where we're trying to convey a very
strong emotion but the player isn't
getting that because they're being hit
with this really creepy looking guy so
we focused a lot on our characters
creating unique and interesting
characters this is Hannah for those of
you who have seen our trailer or played
our single player and we wanted to give
them a sense of realism and not have
them be to exaggerate it in any way we
believe that real characters are the
most interesting because they are the
most relatable we wanted to make sure
that we had human animations and effects
to convey emotion as I said without
entering then County Valley and I think
we got a lot closer with this game
we also wanted to improve in the area of
drama being more dramatic with our
storytelling our effects and our audio
we wanted to focus again on the player
so that the player feels more rewarded
and recognized for what they're doing
and we also wanted to add this feeling
of importance and drama to the player's
actions so here's an example of one of
the references that we were looking at
for our single-player airfield level we
didn't want to tell small stories like
you know a can by the side of the street
you know the story was some guy littered
that's not very exciting we want to tell
entire environment stories which would
convey one big incident and that we
wanted that to have an emotional impact
so for instance this is probably
probably people evacuating for some
reason maybe a hurricane and that made
it into this part of our single player
where we use this reference as a
gameplay wall not allowing the player to
move beyond the support of his squad
also we had a lot of over-the-top
destruction which is always fun please
that's our kick through the city you got
point
so you can see how when you approach
that wall there's some sort of story
these people had evacuated the city and
what we were trying to tell was that it
was under siege there was a big war
going on and the EMP had gone off so
everybody abandoned their cars while
they were leaving and it had left this
big backup so we had to obviously run a
tank over it to get through that's the
best option so we approached
environmental storytelling in a fairly
obvious way this is a fence that I put
in our level very quickly to show a
point this fence communicates to the
player this place is fenced off don't go
here but how do we take that to the next
level what if they're really explorative
well you know we could add an electrical
box with a sign that indicates that
there's some danger don't approach this
we could take this step further adding
effects and audio something buzzing
their effects from an electrical circuit
so maybe this fence is electrified so
you touch it you get hurt we could go
over the top with this and tell a little
bit more of the story but that was a
little bit further than we wanted to go
so we decided to pull it back to about
this level of storytelling for us and
this helps communicate expectations to
the player so that they're not met with
something that doesn't make sense to
them we wanted really clear and obvious
rules in our world we wanted our effects
as I said to create more drama for the
player and that was in having a lot of
atmospheric stuff like dense air mist
fog ambient smoke a lot of dynamic
effects that helped the scene come alive
so here you'll see a clip of that level
without effects and then with effects
you can see that it makes quite a bit of
a difference to how you feel even though
you still have the camera shake and you
still have some shader effects you're
not getting the full impact emotionally
of having all those effects
battering you to the side and making you
feel very helpless and alone audio is
also a very strong tool for creating
drama on a conscious as well as a
subconscious level and our audio team
which is won tons of awards wanted to
make sure that this new game also
maintained that level for quality that
we were well known for we thought that
audio created an environment
environmental ambience that was like an
emotional cushion for the player to sit
on wherever there were things that might
pull the player out of the experience
the audio can pull them back in so this
video clip is about our gunfire so it's
a little bit loud but there it's
reference footage taken from a training
day drill not in a war zone so hopefully
you can see what we're going for
as you can see the pattern is really
easy to discern here in the firing which
kind of makes it feel more like AI more
robotic here's the reference you are
looking at a lot of single fire shotgun
you'll notice and then when they fire on
automatic or semi-automatic dev a bit
longer burst your left's addictive all
but a lot more single fire bursts at
very odd intervals and then here's how
we implemented that in our test range
so those of you that don't work in audio
this may seem like a really subtle
difference but when you're playing the
game and you hear all these ambient
sounds that fit into the world that
you're in it just helps to create this
illusion this bubble of immersion for
the player that being said we also
wanted to improve in the area of
believability this meant refocusing on
infrastructure how our spaces felt the
effects and again the animation we
believe infrastructure is extremely
important to giving a space a sense of
structure and believability it needs
structure and infrastructure for it to
function in real life so subconsciously
we expect these things when we go
through spaces things like road signs
traffic lights sidewalk transitions you
can see here between the road and the
sidewalk we have like a little white
decal and then a darker patch and then
the actual curb and then another darker
patch of tiles leading to a bit of a
faded transition into the texture and
even though that's a lot of transitional
pieces they're all clustered right at
the edge to help you believe this
transition between surfaces the same
goes for our spaces we didn't want to
simplify our spaces we wanted to capture
what was believable instead of
specifically replicating things which
was extremely time-consuming instead of
just saying here's a google image make
that that was a little bit silly we
wanted to capture what was believable
the transitions between surfaces the
material properties especially here in
such a very wet and specular world you
can see especially on the Vespa down
there it has a really nice sort of
specular highlight that really sells
that that's a wet metallic object right
now in the real world no object is just
snapped to the ground or Auto rotated 45
degrees so we really tried to avoid that
in our spaces even from a very early
implementation standpoint from design we
wanted to avoid that trees are always
slightly slanted
they follow the contour of the landscape
man-made things also have imperfections
so we didn't want any razor sharp edges
on our buildings or any of our models so
we decided that it was important to
respect the surfaces of where objects
were placed what is the material that
they're on is it placed on a slope is
the ground soft or hard take your time
to look at these things and understand
why things grow the way they do or why
they're place the way they do and your
worlds will become so much more
believable the same goes for when you're
approaching it from say a design
standpoint here's the problem I need
three pieces of cover but it starts to
look a bit unrealistic and if you start
from this point it's a bit hard to fix
when you're later on down the road so
from from the beginning we wanted to
make sure that we had an organic feel to
how the rocks were placed how cover was
placed working with the landscape in the
terrain rather than just relying on
objects we wanted to rotate and add
variation and then use foliage as a way
to ground objects where does the grass
grow you could take this even further
and say well the grass usually grows on
the sunny side of the rock not on the
shadowed side so whatever is east in
your map would have a little bit more
grass and the other side of the rock
would have more twigs and leaves and
stuff that is built up and not
necessarily been grown over with
vegetation we also wanted more
believable animation and because we use
a lot of mocap with hand tweaked
positions to get this sort of hyper
realism and animation we wanted to make
sure that the characters felt connected
to the world because it's really easy
for them to feel disconnected when
they're standing there in their idle
loop just kind of floating a bit so we
use this by having additional props that
they interacted with by having them sit
in chairs hold coffee cups pick things
up put them down which added a lot of
believability to them so focus that on
that in the scene it may be a little bit
of an extreme example but notice how
they're interacting with
and it helps their movements be more
believable why are y'all still around
short version man we are caught behind
enemy lines we wish to get back to our
ship if wishes were horses you beggars
would ride the US that's ball curry
likely in the Red Sea vine now [ __ ] me
did you fall off where's my coffee man
it is imperative that we find transport
West Russians rolled into our airfield
three days ago more ground forces are
closing in our supply lines are cut off
we're outnumbered 12 to 1 so whatever
your imperative is it's unfortunately
not mine put that down this does pure
devastation
of course Irish is always touching
explosives always getting into trouble
we wanted the same in terms of our audio
the level of consistency should be
really high so we developed this
technique of comparing our audio to
real-world reference that we found again
this is the same piece of reference from
earlier or well it's the same group from
a military training reference we wanted
it to feel very real and documentary
rather than Hollywood and over-the-top
and this was achieved through constant
comparison of carefully chosen real
reference material by analyzing and
deconstructing well chosen big pictures
and letting that define all of the
aspects of the building blocks rather
than the other way around we made sure
that all the assets could fit into the
same image at the same time so that way
your grenade being thrown and hitting a
wall wouldn't sound incredibly different
from you no one in the real world and
the same with you know rapid fire or
single shot fire various guns they
wouldn't feel like this is from a sci-fi
game or from a fantasy game which why
would they have guns in a fantasy game
I'm not sure this is an example here's
the raw footage from the actual
reference
and here's the same reference but with
battlefield 4 audio assets that you're
working on
so as you can see they're a bit heavier
but they still fit let's hit the [ __ ]
corner right there let's hit the [ __ ]
quarter right there so as you can see it
works fairly well as a tool for
comparing your audio and I recommend it
for anyone that's trying to follow a
piece of reference be at a film or a TV
show or a cartoon or something to
compare your audio if you're trying to
replicate a certain type of sound or
feel here's a quick example from
battlefield 4 this is our single player
trailer for those of you that haven't
seen it we wanted all of the elements in
this to come together to form a cohesive
emotional experience telling a story
through conveying an emotion and the
emotion that we have in this trailer and
in the game arcs from a point of
difficulty to loss in desperation and
then determination because they're
caught behind enemy lines there all
alone they don't have the resources of
their entire army
you boys are late takes time to shoot
your way through a search party
what do you mean the effects they're
having a big emotional impact with the
EMP field billion people do not get that
min Qiang more reason to be upset about
the fleet of warships we got stationed
right off his coast no room for mistakes
boys a full of us to get the no I mean
what are you crazy need everyone alive
and combat ready I don't trust her she's
hiding something keep an eye on earth
what is your problem you don't like
having a woman in your squad problem
women I got a problem with live
one gets left behind
of course more destruction or something
about
I know we're tired
all of a sudden
boss friend love
we will ensure it was not
maybe the only ship left
try to speed turn
like the storage areas
together we walked off did you just
invaded China
of course are very well known
battlefield theme music so I wanted to
talk a little bit about frostbite 3 and
what that was like to work with with
some of the new tech elements that we
had coming into the game which were very
exciting but also it required us to
learn how to use new technology and how
to work with that adapter content to
that it was really great to get updates
and new tech during production but it
had some drawbacks integration growing
pains and like I said redoing content so
our planning had to include a lot of
padding to account for this sometimes
new tech can come at a cost as I said
rebuilding content was not always happy
so we needed to create shaders with
dynamic and reactive properties to the
world that were not overly heavy and
loaded that was tough because as an
artist you always want to throw in just
that extra little blend or that extra
little fade but all the extra math
really adds up here the same applied for
our vegetation and our meshes they had
to look really good skinned when they
were just normal and in a plain sunny
windless day but they also have to look
good when they were pulled to the
extremes of their rig and pushed one in
a really windy environment so we tried
to use the same assets as much as much
as possible instead of building unique
ones for every single scenario but when
it comes together it's really worth it
and here's a quick clip from our
frostbite team on some of the features
that we got for battlefield 4 from
frostbite 3
and it's gonna play a minute there we go
we spend significant effort on creating
more dynamic and living environments
before they would have to go to a lot of
work to make a tree feel like it's
weighed in the wind now we give them the
tools to create the tree and we let the
game engine control how the wind effect
century frostbite allows everything to
work together the waves on the beach the
wind blowing the right caps even the
clouds overhead I'll move consistently
with the forces of nature you might see
an explosion go off you'll see the trees
nearby shake from the explosion it's
sort of subtle but it creates this sense
that seamless reality so the large world
coupled with a lot of people running
around interacting with you really pays
off and though
destruction has always been a core
feature of frostbite dungeon it's the
evolution of the way the environment is
impacted by gameplay everything from the
smallest spark colliding but also
gigantic chunks of debris that crumble
when they impact the ground the guys on
battlefield 4 have been working on
something called revolution revolution
it's really about the console how you
can drastically change
it could be anything from a big building
collapsing or to a damn breaking or
anything really big game changes at
level
a recent feature that we've put in and
you'll see in battlefield 4 is our
networked water simulation so what this
means is all players will see the same
way than the same position at the same
time this leads to some pretty exciting
the cat-and-mouse type of gameplay we're
ducking down and going up and you keep
around as you drive into your boat there
was no longer a swim on a flat surface
instead it will be affected by the
different waves and everything and that
comes to everything from living
characters that are swimming but also to
the ragdolls something like a jet
crashes into the ocean you'll see the
water react and
so as you can see we had a lot of new
features that came in with frostbite 3
and this was happening during production
so it's not like we started a few years
before battlefield 4 released and we had
all that great tech obviously new tech
takes time to develop and we came up
with ideas as we were in pre-pro so
asking for stuff and getting that back
was a really great resource and it was
really worth it in the end to get this
new tech and to rebuild our content
because i think it created a much more
solid game in the end I want to talk
quickly about our destruction because
that's such a big feature in battlefield
something we're very well known for our
goals with battlefield 4 were to create
the feeling of a fully dynamic and
physical world that you can interact
with things respond the way they should
if you kick a chair it'll fall over if
you throw a grenade at a wall if it
isn't like super reinforced steel you
know it'll take some damage it'll show
that destruction we wanted to deliver a
destruction experience does visually and
sonically mind-blowing which means that
it was both audible audibly mind-blowing
but sonic approves and we realized that
since we can't have destruction on all
of our objects just for practical
performance reasons we needed to have a
crystal clear visual language to the
player that described what was
destructible and what wasn't so that's
subconsciously even if they weren't
aware of it they would know that well
obviously this wall is destructible and
that one isn't so they wouldn't just
launched RPGs at walls and be really
disappointed when they didn't get
destroyed we also used a good visual
language throughout the rest of our game
obviously if it's red it'll blow up it's
a classic we also had yellow pipes that
had poison gas and I think blue had
water and some other sort of iconic like
flashing lights for things that you
could interact with so at different
types of destruction in battlefield 4
that we worked with the first one was
micro destruction
this is when small arms fire chips off
parts of an asset this generally
consists of smaller pieces and a ruin
state for the explosion destruction it
allows vehicles to move over small
objects without problems at the very end
when you have a ruined state and it
communicates the player that this asset
is completely destroyed so you'll see
when I play this clip that I'll blow up
parts of this or I'll shoot parts of
this asset but there's always a bit of a
ruin left at the bottom so that there's
still something there micro to stop
destruction mostly is aesthetic and adds
to an overall feeling of pressure let's
say you're taking cover behind something
that's like crouch cover height and
pieces are getting chipped off and
flying in your face it adds this sense
of importance and drama and anxiety but
it doesn't really add large gameplay
changes or memorable events and it is
the most expensive of all of our types
of destruction so we only use it in
areas where the player is going to take
frequent cover such as around high
populated capture points so as you can
see there are various parts of the
object and those have health states so
when I shoot that and it takes damage
it'll
they replaced with these
cluster effect
we also had macro destruction which is a
larger damage two holes like holes in
walls this allows players to create new
routes and increase visibility
throughout the level for all those super
evil snipers out there I was brought in
from a tank and I dived the window after
knifing it it missed me and blow the
holes with a wall in front of me then I
run to the next door and then try to hit
me again it blows the wall score in
front of me so I'm just keep running
through the whole this blog but while
still trying to hit me directly it was
unbelievable maybe a bit of an extreme
example but definitely has happened to
me sometimes in the game and then we
have building destruction we have
structures that collapse after a certain
amount of player induced damage players
usually are killed if they're caught
inside this collapse and these collapses
are meant to change the game play area
and the roots in a larger way so let's
say you have a two-story building but
then it collapses you might still have
some cover underneath on one side but
you can now like run over the top or
around and I apologize in advance for
the frame rate I was running like four
versions of the game at the same time
when I was capturing this and as you
will see I was also running spikes
I asked you guys to turn your cell
phones off but then I couldn't turn
skype off hypocrisy and then we also
have our cinematic destruction which is
what everyone recognizes and remembers
from our trailers and also from our
levels it's the most memorable and it's
always linked to the theme of the level
we try to make these spectacular with
big animations and we want them to
change the way the level is played the
most so for instance the skyscraper in
Cedar Shanghai when that comes down it
changes to a different game play area
for the main middle base and the same on
I think it's called flood zone you can
break a damn and it raises the entire
water level in the city so instead of
using vehicles you now use water
vehicles
so those are always big and over-the-top
who doesn't like a little bit of big and
over-the-top I know I do so as I
mentioned earlier we needed to be really
smart with the placement of our
destruction we couldn't just put it
everywhere and we couldn't just put the
most expensive stuff in places people
wouldn't see it because that's not smart
we wanted a higher density of
destructible props at points that were
likely to be contested and highly
populated so we usually around our sea
bass but then we also had some at all of
our other bases but we usually wouldn't
put it like on the edges of the city
where no one is likely to go the same
principle applies to more interesting
areas and iconic objects in our level as
well the more expensive or costly they
are we tend to put them in the middle
where people will get to see them
because who wants to work on a really
pretty object and then no one gets to
see it that wouldn't be fun so this is
cesar shanghai the left side is a spawn
based on the right side of the spawn
base and the tower in the middle is the
middle base and as you can see we we
took that principle to the extreme here
where the middle base is the giant
LEvolution destructible building that
falls down but there's also a higher
density of micro destruction props there
and macro destruction cascades out to
the other bases as well that way players
feel like they're getting some kind of
cool interact ability with the
environment that it is physical that it
does respond to what you're doing I want
to talk quickly about l'évolution
because that was a new feature that we
introduced in battlefield and really
it's just a way for the level to respond
to the player to evolve dynamically as
you're playing the changes are either
passive or active storytelling and
cosmetic or tactical with destruction or
level changing features they're not
always destruction it could be like
you'll see there the the raising of the
shutters when we were first testing a
lot of our l'évolution features however
we noticed that not a lot of people
realized they were there and when they
were triggered or something did happen
not a lot of people knew that it
happened so we decided after doing some
testing to approach it by informing the
player making them aware of what exists
by using mechanics and techniques that
are familiar to gamers like I said
flashing lights different materials the
red barrel that explodes we use this
sort of interaction language to help
inform the player of what's available
and what has happened we also needed to
reset crank it to 11 but we need to make
sure the player feels the event and
notices when something has changed so
that they're not confused when they come
back and suddenly the area is very
different so we have audio we have the
effects when you're closer to an event
but you're not really looking at it
sometimes you'll have a little screen
effect the most notable of this is
probably after the skyscraper comes down
on that level siege of Shanghai there's
a shader that gets placed on all the
objects it passes around there's effects
that go through the street and then a
dust shader that settles on all of the
objects so that even if you spawn into
the level after this has happened you
know the skyscraper is down so that way
you're not grabbing a sniper role you're
grabbing a tank to go annihilate people
at Point C we also wanted to add a bang
and maximize the potential and emotional
impact of all this which is why we like
added a big spectacle spectacle to
everything lots of effects over the top
so the goal with LEvolution was to add
new elements without removing focus from
our core battlefield experience and they
made a lot of changes throughout the way
we realized very early on that sometimes
the easiest levolution features to
implement like bollards raising up to
stop traffic often had the biggest
effect on gameplay so we asked the
entire studio to come up with ideas for
what levolution features they would like
to see what kind of interactable stuff
in the level they would like to see and
that generated a ton of ideas that we
sifted through and it helped create the
most effective mechanics to put effort
in time into our LEvolution pod is a
good example
of cross-disciplinary and work in the
industry and we're very excited that
they did well in that it demanded a lot
of constant testing but also a really
great technical understanding a
willingness to take on challenges and it
also needed a sense of imagination which
is probably one of the things that most
of us love about working in the games
industry being able to use the process
of rapid iteration the LEvolution team
was able to prototype rule out redo
refine and polish a lot of concepts from
ideation to implementation I'm just
going to show a quick video where our
producer is talking about some
l'évolution features it can be anything
like writing all new paths to get the
upper hand in the fight race bollards to
stop week fortify your position by
activating the strategy or how about
wrapping your enemy with one of your
hands names that one's my favorite
metal detectors will give me position
away
and car alarms can really screw up your
life
disorient your enemies by using the
environment to gain a tactical advantage
then there's the ambient changes that
will drastically alter the look at the
shader a detacher across the Bethel
finally you can trigger massive game
changing event you can flood an entire
city changing the title
LEvolution is a game-changer it's a big
focus for us as we take the dynamics of
battlefield it's a whole new level
pretty fun I like it now I go back and
play other FPS and I'm like why can't I
interact with everything I also wanted
to talk about our water and weather sub
system as you guys saw in the frostbite
video we have a new server synced water
simulation system that allows all of our
players to see the same waves at the
same time we ended up using an approach
that we call our visual target for a lot
of this because we have so much content
over so many maps we wanted to create a
base set of assets that could be used
everywhere that would react to whatever
environment they were put in so we had a
woodland visual target with trees that
were properly skinned and looked good
with foliage with terrain shaders with
water shaders that could be used on all
of those environments throughout the
game the same went for our ocean and
beach themed our islands and our
interior in our snowy sort of
environment so we had these visual
targets and then world builders or
designers could go in grab those shaders
grab those assets and they would
automatically work together in a scene
and then when you added wind or you
wanted to change the weather of the
level they would react and they would
look good under those conditions like i
said this demanded that a lot of our
content was very flexible and that was
probably one of the harder things to do
was go back and make shaders that would
look good when the water was completely
Placid but then would froth up and get a
little darker and look still solid like
good water when it became a lot more
stormy I wanted to show you guys our
visual target for the woodland
environment just so you get an idea and
this was really early on in production
so some of the assets got updated but
you'll still see kind of how we created
that
so as you can see we have around maybe
four or five different terrain shaders
here different scattered meshes on the
ground such as leaves or twigs grass on
the other side we have bushes we have
small sapling trees we have larger trees
and plenty of lens flares
we have to make sure that a lot of our
assets like rocks that were being used
for level design quite frequently we're
very solid so that from early on we're
getting good content into our levels
that we didn't have to go back in and
replace it with new content later on
also is really relaxing after being in a
place with a bunch of gunfire to just
drop into one of our visual targets have
that nice calm music so I wanted to say
a big thank you to all of you all of you
at GDC all of you who play our game
everybody that supports us in the
community big thank you from the
multiplayer team and also from the rest
of the battlefield 4 development team I
also want to extend a huge thank you to
the GDC board for organizing this event
and the technique technicians who keep
everything running smoothly and the
conference associate associates we
couldn't do any of this without you guys
so please warm round of applause